good morning Hank it's Tuesday so as you
know the Yeti and I have a lot of books
like we have several thousand books in
our house at any given time I mean even
Henry is a pretty significant book
collection and he's too so like I do
feel a little bit qualified recommend
books I'm often asked what my favorite
book is I don't have a favorite book I
have hundreds but today since it's the
holiday gift season and all I thought
I'd recommend some books in turn if you
then you format example if you like
Fifty Shades of Grey
then you can find lots of that stuff on
the internet for free ok let's start if
you like the fictional exploits of this
women town food we poopers you might
also like The Ballad of the whiskey
robber an amazing true story about a
Hungarian hockey player who is a
professional hockey goalie and a bank
robber also a prison escapee but I don't
want to spoil anything ok if you're
interested in to racing worldsuck or
knows someone who is you might like
behind the beautiful forevers the most
interesting and complex book about
poverty I have ever read that makes it
sound really sad and unfun but it isn't
sad it's a little bit sad it's just
great read it for fans of The Catcher in
the Rye what gift book do I recommend
it's going to be a surprise
Sula by Toni Morrison if catcher is the
Great American Novel of growing up
without a friend I think Sula is the
great American novel about friendship in
adolescence found a be nerds I recommend
Mansfield Park persuasion really any
Jane Austen novel I mean the costume
designed in those novels is fantastic if
you like my book The Fault in Our Stars
thanks I also recommend that you read
Peter Teresa's book the blood of the
Lamb if you liked The Hunger Games this
is hard because I'm a huge fan of
dystopias I'm gonna go scott
westerfeld's ugly series also a leak on
DS match series and Veronica Roth's
infuriatingly unfinished divergent
series give me an ending if you're
interested in reading a book together
with your romantic partner the two books
the Eddie and I read together this year
and liked the most were Telegraph Avenue
by Michael shaven shave on cheb I don't
know how to say his last name and
Bossypants by Tina fie fie hey I don't
know if you like the Harry Potter books
you should just read them again they
stand up to rereading but you should
also read web Grossman's the magician
series which is a very knowing and
wonderful take on the wizard school
genre and if you want to read a great
book about the Harry Potter fandom I
recommend Harry a history by melissa ann
le how about you want to read a novel
where you just care so much about the
characters and you don't even understand
why I recommend the art of fielding by
Chad Harbach or Marcus zoo's axe The
Book Thief
is good also Markus Zusak is so handsome
it's frustrating oh they'll tell him I
said is there anything but Markus Zusak
has fantastic muscles crash course world
history fans who enjoy fiction let me
recommend two very long books that you
will not regret reading Wolf Hall and
the astonishing life Octavian nothing
traitor to the nation volumes 1 & 2
crash course biology enthusiasts I am a
huge fan of the Emperor of all maladies
also great title if you're looking for
Alaska fan who mostly liked the boarding
school parts that I recommend the
disreputable history of frankie landau
banks by E Lockhart and if you like to
no spoilers parts then I recommend
everybody sees the ants by a s king and
if I Stay by Gayle Forman who viens you
thought I wasn't gonna get you but it's
fine I recommend the great and
underappreciated to say nothing of the
dog by Connie Willis which is maybe my
favorite time travel book ever
and Sherlock fans this is gonna sound
crazy but stay with me I recommend that
you read The Adventures of Sherlock
Holmes by Sir Arthur Conan Doyle also I
think you'd like PD James a lot so those
are my holiday book buying
recommendations for nerdfighters
everywhere nerdfighters I'm interested
to know what you think I should be
reading so let me know in comments and
lastly a gentle reminder books
especially those purchased at your local
bookstore make great gifts make over the
years I've received and enjoyed many
wonderful gifts but none have lasted as
long as the books I mean here is the
copy of ship breaker that you got me for
Christmas a few years ago here's the
copy of the Human Stain that Sarah gave
me when we first started dating this is
the edition of micro surfs that dad
bought me for Christmas in 1997 and this
is where the Red Fern Grows which mom
got me for Christmas when I was 10 so
give me your book recommendations please
consider giving books over the holidays
especially mine but also other people's
hanka I will see you on Friday